[Musik]
dicke Bücher
was hat es mit denen auf sich in der
U-Bahn und dem Bus sehe ich keine mehr
da sehe ich nur noch Telefone
und dennoch gibt es immer wieder Leute
die sagen sie wollen ein Buch bewohnen
sie wollen es bei sich haben sie können
kaum aufhören
und überhaupt stimmt es wahrscheinlich
dass die langen Texte in der Literatur
und am tiefsten engagieren
und kann ich zum schnellen wieder Lesen
animieren eben weil das Buch zu
umfangreich ist aber doch am längsten
bei uns bleiben es soll also heute um
ein dickes Buch gehen heute am Sonntag
den 5. Dezember ich bin Paul Ingendaay
und ich freue mich dass Sie dabei sind
[Musik]
als 2007 der monumentale Roman Leben und
Schicksal des sowjetischen
Schriftstellers Basilique Rossmann
erstmals vollständig auf Deutsch
erschienen da war von einem
sensationellen literarischen Fund ja von
einem Jahrhundertroman die Rede wieso
hatte diese wieder Entdeckung so lange
gedauert naja Rossmann hatte als
jüdischer Schriftsteller und knallharter
Realist immer zwischen den Stilen
gesessen die Wahrheit sagen und was es
kostet das könnte als Motto über seinem
Leben stehen geboren wurde er 1905 in
berdichev in der heutigen Ukraine
und als er 1964 starb waren seine
Hauptwerke entweder verstümmelt oder gar
nicht erschienen seine Papiere
konfisziert und er selbst als Dissident
zu Unperson erklärt worden
ich möchte also als erstes heute eine
Kerze anzünden für Autoren die weiter
gemacht haben obwohl es im Leben nie
einen Lohn dafür gab nicht in Rom nicht
die Kohle nicht die Vorteile oder das
andere und doch haben sie durchgehalten
die sowjetische Literaturgeschichte um
sie mal so zu nennen ist voll von ihnen
Rossmann hat übrigens auch einen der
ersten ausführlichen Berichte über das
Vernichtungslager Treblinka verfasst ich
habe mir vor mir liegen die Hölle von
Treblinka
nicht nur sehr lesenswert einfach eine
erschütternde Lektüre eines frühen
Augenzeugen der einige der wenigen
Überlebenden sprechen konnte
Rossmann hatte ich sogar getraut
Treblinka in der sowjetischen
Öffentlichkeit als jüdisches Lager zu
bezeichnen das war ein Ding damals in
dem regierenden Antisemitismus der
Stalinzeit Rossmann wir jetzt daraus
sehen war sehr mutig
ja leben und Schicksal der 2007
wiederentdeckte riesen Roman hat einen
kaum weniger bedeutenden Vorgänger und
und denen geht es heute Stalingrad
Normalität in einer sorgfältigen
Übertragung und annähernder
Vollständigkeit auf Deutsch vor er ist
fast 1300 Seiten stark und er wurde
übersetzt auf der Grundlage einer
Textfassung die der Übersetzer rüber
Chandler erstellt und zwanzig neunzehn
auf Englisch veröffentlicht hat nur
beide Romane zusammen als dilogie oder
als Dip dich schon ergeben das wirklich
ambitionierte Werk das dem Künstler
Grossmann vorschwebte ein Epos über den
Deutschen Krieg gegen die Sowjetunion
auf allen Ebenen der Gesellschaft bomba
Zerstörung die deutschen Lager
sowjetischen Gulag und immer aus der
Sicht einzelner Menschen und dann wieder
aus der Sicht einer Gruppe einer Familie
eines Truppenverband
es handelt sich um eine Analyse der
totalitarisme nin Großmanns Zeit ein
Zeugnis millionenfach wenn ich den
Lebens aber auch unbeugsamer Hopfen und
um eine Hommage an die Toten und kann
die Handlung des Romans kaum andeuten so
so groß ist sie weit gespannt so viele
Schicksale
marschieren hierauf und doch ist
Stalingrad kein kriegsroman der geht aus
von der Familie schaposchnikow und ihrem
Umfeld Essen schon mehrere Generationen
erweise sich zu einem Panorama und einem
kollektiven Portrait der sowjetischen
Gesellschaft Offiziere Infanteristen
Lokalpolitiker Kolchos Bauern
Stahlarbeiter Betreuerinnen des
Kinderheims die Kinder selbst natürlich
dann unter dem Zeichen drohender
Vernichtung zwischen Sommer 1942 und der
endgültigen militärischen Niederlage der
deutschen Wehrmacht im Februar 43
dieser Wassili semjonowitsch Grossman
wir vollständig hier soir
ausgewählter Chemiker und das Interesse
an Naturwissenschaft spielt im Roman
eine Rolle hat junger Mann war mit
Kurzgeschichten hervorgetreten begabt
gehalten worden sogar von Gorki
gefördert einen der mächtigen Männer des
Literaturbetrieb selber einem großen
Auto bei seinem ersten umfangreichen
Roman hatte Grossmann ein präzises
Vorbild vor Augen Krieg und Frieden von
Tolstoi und entscheiden Unterschied ist
dass Tolstoi seinen großen Roman über
Napoleons Feldzug gegen das russische
Zarenreich
50 Jahre nach den Ereignissen verfasst
hat während Rossmann mitten im
Gefechtsstand er war ja für untauglich
befunden worden und nun verbrachte er
also als Kriegsreporter drei Jahre bei
den sowjetischen Truppen er hat alles
gesehen und einige der härtesten
Schlachten miterlebt
in Stalingrad finden diese Erfahrungen
ein Echo viele wurden in Notizbüchern
festgehalten einige dieser Aufzeichnung
kennen wir
hilft der Blick auf Nebenfiguren des
Infernos wenigen Zeilen nur skizziert
ist erschütternd gib ein Satz den ich
nur unterstrichen habe und der mag ihn
jetzt sind wir vorkommen aber ich finde
ihn unglaublich
seltsam schienen die Veränderungen und
seltsam wirkte das unveränderte das ist
der Blick rossmanns auf den Krieg auf
eine Kriegsszenario auf eine Landschaft
seltsam schienen die Veränderungen und
seltsam wirkt das unveränderte auch die
Sterbenden Tiere halten bei Grossmann
ihrem Trauergesang die Pferde die Vögel
die Hunde die Ratten und die Tauben die
auffliegen und die von ihrem Schlag
nicht wegkommen und deswegen verbrennen
eine der Hauptfiguren der Sowjet
Kommissar krimov sieht einmal eine Reihe
Infanteristen die Straße entlang gehen
ich zitiere mit gesenkten Köpfen mit
finsteren gequälten Gesichtern
steht er sich die Frage ob die mit den
finsteren Gesichtern ist wohl in die
Bücher schaffen das ist eine der
zahlreichen Passagen in denen der
Tolstoi Verehrer Grossmann sein
berühmten Vorläufer herausfordert und
der folgert
dieser Anblick war nichts für
Schriftsteller die den Krieg später
einmal in erhabene weiße Gewänder
erhöhen würden
tja
denn hier geht es um eine Zeit die bis
heute weiter wirkt
Rossmann zeigt auch es geht um die
persönliche Verantwortung des Einzelnen
am Gang der Geschichte
in einem Jahrhundert in dem die
Vernichtung eine Sache aller geworden
ist erkennt Grossmann den einzigen
Rettungsanker in individueller Moral man
kann es auch anders sagen der Platz des
Schriftstellers der sich die Wahrheit
dieses mörderischen jahrhundert
vorgenommen hat kann nur an der Seite
der Opfer sein
[Musik]
ich freue mich jetzt sehr dass ich hier
mit Christiane Körner Sitze 1 von 3
Übersetzerinnen Übersetzern und
Übersetzerinnen des Romans Stalingrad
von Wassili Grossman um den es ja bei
uns heute geht ich war immer fasziniert
davon was Übersetzerinnen tun wenn sie
mit einem solchen Text Ringen saß ein
solchen riesen Text und ich weiß aber
auch dass Übersetzer und Übersetzerinnen
den Text so gut kennen wie kaum jemand
sonst nicht einmal die Kritiker die
nachher lesen und angeblich zweimal
lesen und dann ihre Sachen schreiben
oder erzählen kennen den Text so genau
wie die Menschen die ihn auswringen
müssen um an den Kern zu kommen die
Ausdrücke Alternativen entsprechend
finden müssen für das was wir im
Original vor uns sehen deswegen frage
ich auf einmal Frau Körner was sind für
Sie die Stärken des Erzählers Grossmann
die kennen Sie ja wenn Sie diese Sätze
auf russisch was ich sehen und die
müssen dem seine Entsprechung finden
dafür was inklusive stärken die Tugenden
was zieht sie an am Erzähler vassilikos
mal was zieht nicht an da weiß ich kaum
wo ich beginnen soll aber das wirklich
sehr sehr viel ist und es fängt eben an
bei der zu beeindruckenden Authentizität
wir wissen ja dass es ist es eine
Zeugenschaft die in autorisiert hat
dieses Buch so zu schreiben wie es
geschrieben hat er war als
Kriegsberichterstatter die ganze Zeit
dabei praktisch vom ersten Tag an und
bis zur Einnahme von Berlin mit wenigen
Unterbrechungen
das zweite ist vielleicht ich meine es
gibt andere Texte über den Krieg auf der
Sowjetunion diese ungeheure
Wahrhaftigkeit die in auszeichnet also
man spürt wenn man die Grossmann liest
man diesen Roman liest das ganz viel
durch seinen Kopf gegangen ist ganz
viele Gespräche geführt worden ganz
viele Beobachtungen gemacht worden bevor
er seine Sätze schreibt also sozusagen
die die die Sätze und Absätze sind
gesättigt von Erleben von Fragen von
zuhören von reflektieren und im von ihr
haben von Unna bis 4 Realität so wie sie
eben wirklich auch war es ist
interessant weil sie das ja erwähnen er
war ja Kriegsberichterstatter für die
Zeitung Roter Stern ja über drei Jahre
hatte das gemacht und als ich in einem
anderen Band dir schon vor Jahren
erschienen ist ein Schriftsteller im
kriegen herausgehen von Anthony B weil
ich da Lars wie man seine Texte
Aufnahmen und dass er zum beliebtesten
und bekanntesten
Berichterstatter wurde wegen der
Wahrhaftigkeit von der sie gerade
gesprochen als hat mich sehr bewegt denn
wie kann man das werden unter solchen
Bedingungen im Krieg dass die Texte
dieses Autors laut vorgelesen wurden die
Leute hören wollten wie dieser Mann den
Krieg für sie besteht den Krieg in die
selber stecken ja ich mein laut
vorgelesen dann musst du schon weil es
zu wenig ist Sarah Garten und dann wurde
immer abgestimmt welchen Text sollen wir
lesen weil das Exemplar schnell
weitergegeben werden musste begrenzte
Zeit und dann gibt es wirklich Zeugnisse
das dann sehr oft ist Grossmann
Grossmann er hat eben keine Helden
Geschichten erzählt die aus den Fingern
gezogen waren also er hat da nicht etwas
überhöht ja er hat eben Menschen
beschrieben einfache Menschen und keine
Helden es gibt ja in dem Buch auch so
ein winziges Kapitel was im Grunde die
Poetik seines Schreibens wiedergibt also
eben Stichwort noch mal Wahrhaftigkeit
er spricht davon von höchster
Schlichtheit die erreicht werden soll
nichts ausgeklügeltes nichts ausgedacht
ist aber diese Schlichtheit vergleicht
er dann mit dem weißen Tageslicht das
aus der höchsten Komplexität der
Gesamtheit aller Spektralfarben er sich
zusammensetzt und das ist für mich so
das zweite Geheimnis aber das ist kein
Geheimnis ist liegt an der Oberfläche
aber der zweite Punkt Rossmann gibt
unendlich viele Perspektiven wieder und
damit meine ich nicht nur dass er neben
dem Kriegsgeschehen ja eine riesen
Familiensaga im Grunde erzählt obwohl
der der Zeitraum des Erzählens daran
sich so wenige Monate bei Stalingrad ist
sondern er nimmt die Perspektive ganz
unterschiedlicher Menschen ein es gibt
wenn man den Anfang des Romans sich
anguckt das ist ja ein riesen Panorama
eine ganz riesige Perspektive also
Hitler und Mussolini treffen sich in
Salzburg und das ist ein auktorialer
Erzähler allwissender Erzähler der da
etwas beschreibt gerade zum Ende des
Kapitels heißt es dann ja die meisten
der hier anwesenden werden innerhalb
überschaubarer Zeit tot sein und dann
gibt's einen ganz harten Schnitt und wir
sind in der Hose und eine wahnsinnig
sympathische Figur der Chorus arbeite
vavilov bekommt eine Einberufung und
seine Gefühle seine Wahrnehmung seiner
Umgebung der blickt mit der jetzt auf
seine Kinder guckt auf seine Frau guckt
da sind ja Platz in einer Art tut intim
Innenschau das ist doch dass das tolle
dass er die haben ihn bisher noch nicht
täuscht volgenandt wir müssen ja wohl
nennen eben wegen dieser Fähigkeit das
ganze in den Blick zu nehmen und alle
Etagen des Lebens zu betrachten ich habe
es das Buch erstmal dick wie es ist vor
mir ist dürfen auch unsere höre ein
bisschen mehr das Papier rascheln hören
es sind wirklich acht geschlagene Seiten
Figuren Liste mit Funktionen berufen und
verwandtschaftlichen Beziehungen das
sollte die Lisa nicht abschrecken es
muss es eigentlich aber es darf es nicht
denn diese Figuren Liste ist wichtig für
uns wie schon bei das DSG bei Charles
Dickens hatte man solche Listen um uns
zu orientieren und wir haben ja auch
mehrfach Name die doppelt vorkommen also
dann Brüder haben wir doch mehrere bei
Norway Koffer und anderen Leuten wir
müssen mal kurz nachschlagen können von
denen ich hier gerade die reden haben
wir obendrein noch die dreimal die
dreifachnamen sozusagen im russischen
mit Vatersnamen auch noch
und die vielen Kursen die vielen
Kosenamen das ist doch alles wunderschön
erklärt hier es gibt ja auch wirklich
gute Erläuterungen Einführung in diesem
Buch das also den Zugang möglich macht
aber das was sie vorhin erwähnten nicht
nur Wahrhaftigkeit sollen auch dass er
seine Poetik eigentlich offenlegt im
Buch das ist eine hinreißende Stelle die
anderen Stellen wo er eben mit Tolstoi
wenn man so wie in einen Disput tritt
nämlich
fragt Tolstoi hat in Krieg und Frieden
50 Jahre nach den Ereignissen
geschrieben aber er Wassily grossmann
als Tolstoi Ferreira steckt mitten in
dem was er beschreiben muss und der
beschreibt es in den Jahren und den
wenigen darauf von mir eine den es
geschieht ja voll ich glaube von 43 bis
49 schreibt Rossmann dieses Buch und
dann kommen noch weitere Versionen da
wollen wir es nicht zu tief rein gehen
ist eine sehr komplexe Textgeschichte
die auch in Bochum nach war der gut
erklärt wird für uns wenn ich noch mal
mach die Perspektivität eingehen darf
also was ich so grandios finde ist dass
er nicht nur wirklich unendlich viele
verschiedene Personen vorstellt und uns
in die praktisch rein blicken lässt
sondern wie er das macht also es gibt
immer wieder nicht den alten erzählt
dass es gibt wirklich die ganz personale
Perspektive und am berührendsten ist das
an einigen Stellen wo er ein Kind hat
schade uns mit den Augen von Kindern
blicken lässt oder wo so eine Art Mini
Bewusstseinsstrom bei den Leuten die im
Bergwerk arbeiten losgeht und sozusagen
unsere Ohren dann da rauscht ja oder das
Bombardement das Flächenbombardement
aufhören Stadien gerade das hebt fünf
Mal von Neuem an also die Geschichte der
sozusagen die erste Bombe fällt fünfmal
könnte man sagen und das Grauen beginnt
fünfmal mit jeweils anderen Augen mit
den Augen der Stadt könnte man sagen zu
Beginn des Kollektivs und dann gibt es
jeweils verschiedene Perspektiven von
Personen die man schon kennt und
dadurch ist Rossmann zu dicht an den
Menschen drei also die die Humanität die
Menschlichkeit die man spürt wenn man
das Buch liest die ist dem geschuldet
dass er so dicht an die Einzelperson
rangeht und das sind das Schicksal der
einzelnen Person die Psyche der
einzelnen Person der Einzelfigur
unendlich wichtig ist ich habe das
Empfinden auch gehabt und ich hatte auch
das Gefühl einen großen Einfachheit
innerhalb der Komplexität seines
Schreibens aber es ist eigentlich ein
direktes schildern des
freies ohne Verzierungen ohne
Manierismen ohne gewollte Schönheit ich
finde es von einer von einer Jahr von
einer Reinheit die ich erstaunlich finde
und das eben gepaart mit dem Thema wo es
um die größten Sachen geht Tod Leid
Angst
gelegentlich auch Feigheit nicht viel
aber es gibt sie gibt ja einige wirklich
ihre Szenen von von Feigheit auch aber
auch dann von Durchhaltewillen und von
allem das ist tatsächlich berührend und
ich kenne keine Parallele und wenn ich
das jetzt zum Abschluss unserer dieses
Gesprächszeit kurz sagen darf nur durch
ihre Übersetzung die von ihnen und ihrer
Kollegen haben wir einen Eindruck davon
was dieser große Schriftsteller wollte
ich möchte dann die Chance nutzen und
unbedingt jetzt die Namen meiner beiden
Mitstreiter zu nennen Maria Raja und
Andreas weil wir haben es zu dritt
gemacht bei so einem Werk ist ganz
wichtig wenn man zusammen arbeitet und
ich möchte auch an sein bühling
unbedingt jetzt genannt Wissen der den
Anhang aus dem Englischen übersetzt hat
was er nur deshalb so perfekt konnte
weil er auch Russisch kann ja vielen
Dank
ein sehr interessanter Punkt an diesem
Buch an einer der Ort heute natürlich
beschäftigt um nicht zu sagen auf fühlt
ist das ist ein sowjetischer Autor ist
der seine beiden großen Romane also
Stalingrad und leben und Schicksal zu
zwei verschiedenen Phasen geschrieben
die beiden gehören zusammen das ist ganz
klar an der sind im Grunde ein Doppel
Roman ein großes Werk in zwei Teilen und
man kann sie natürlich separat lesen
aber wenn man das weiß dass es die
beiden Bücher gibt dann muss man dieses
ganze Werk lesen man will es ja auch
wenn man diese diese Klasse vor sich
sieht aber interessant ist eben dass das
früher Buch Stalingrad noch den Geist
der Stalinzeit atmet auch ein bisschen
dieses Orvieto Pathos was das spätere
Werk Leben und Schicksal nicht mehr so
hat er es gibt eine Art von
Desillusionierung im Laufe der zehn
Jahre ne zwischen den beiden Büchern
ganz grob diese Zeitangabe jetzt und ich
fand mich beim nee aber auch auf eine
ungewöhnliche Weise genommen und
hineingesetzt in ein System das längst
untergegangen ist nämlich Arbeiter und
Bauernstaat Kolchose Werktätige Fabriken
Fabrikhallen Bergwerke traktorfabrik
also das Pathos Deindustrialisierung die
übrigens auch unseren
Umweltgedanken natürlich den fand ich
quer dazu steht heute dann nicht da
vorne in dieser gestimmt und es ist
Krach und wie ist das wenn sie das
sozusagen diese Widersprüche die
erfahren Sie als Übersetzerin sieht man
sie lesen ist sie übersetzen ist und die
haben dieses große Werk vor sich das ist
alles Teil der Botschaft aber es ist
auch voller Widerhaken oder ja und das
ist natürlich das interessante also ich
meine immer das so einfach hinnehmen
würde dass Sätze wie die Arbeiter und
Bauern bestimmen ihr Leben also der ist
wirklich
Zelte muss ich sagen eigentlich für so
ein riesiges Werk aber da ist schon
zwischendurch Athos da aber es gibt die
Widerhaken also man könnte ich ja fragen
ist das jetzt wirklich ein Werk des
sozialistischen Realismus so ein
klassisches ja das war die Doktrin die
literarische zu der Zeit was hat
Rossmann da gemacht er hat viele viele
Dinge gemacht diesen partus
zuwiderlaufen und diesem dieser Doktrin
widersprechen wenn man mal beginnt
einfach bei der Figurenzeichnung es gibt
wenige Figuren in dem Buch die eindeutig
negativ oder eindeutig positiv sind weil
es gibt bei den bei den wichtigsten
Figuren Widersprüche weil es gibt so
viele Dinge wir konnten das ja
nachvollziehen mit unserer neuen text
und der rekonstruierten Text Variant
oder rekonstruiert ist nicht ganz
richtig es gibt keine Urfassung aber da
mehr in der Variante die Robbe Chandler
da
zusammengebaut hat aus der gedruckten
Version von 56 und eine sehr sehr freien
sehr lebendigen Variante er was da eben
weggefallen war und was jetzt in unserer
Wehr Variante drin war das war markiert
in unseren Manuskripten und da konnte
ich dann sehen oder konnten wir sehen
dass das von politisch ganz wichtigen
Dingen natürlich ging aber für mich
umwerfend ist dass er in mehreren
Stellen schreibt davon dass es Leute
gibt die auf die deutschen warten und
nicht nur so zwielichtige Menschen in
Dörfern also irgendwo im Hinterland die
fast so eine Art Fest feiern wären die
Rote Armee sich zurückzieht und die
deutschen demnächst kommen werden nein
sondern der vorzeige Arbeiter
schlechthin Andreas der also ein
stahlgießer ist ja so wirklich einer der
vorzeige Figuren wobei der auch so seine
Brüche hat mir erzählt ganz zu Beginn in
einem Gespräch mit einem ehemaligen
revolutionär ja es ist eine Schande
deshalb habe ich es eben in der großen
Runde nicht gesagt aber sogar bei uns in
der Fabrik gibt Leute die auf
Deutschmann das war natürlich alles
stellen die unmöglich gedruckt werden
konnten in den 50er Jahren aber daneben
auch solche Dinge wie in einer Figur
trinkt mal an der Hauptfigur trink mal
nebenher schnell sind sonst Import car
unternommen sich im Mund um die Nerven
wieder auf zu bügeln alles was irgendwie
mit Sexualität zu tun hat alles was mit
Kaution zu tun haben könnte mit
Diebstahl sowie Dusche Werkstätte
Werktätige stehen ich ja sind auch nicht
von Läusen bedeckt die Soldaten keine
Gründe kann man anhand dieser erstellen
so sehen wie steril die Vorgaben waren
wie Stereo der Sozialismus eigentlich
wirklich von seiner ganzen Anlage her
war und wie sehr
Grossmann dafür gekämpft hat ein ganz
anderes Bild zu zeichnen also eben die
Menschen plastisch zu machen es ist
ohnehin dieser Roman mit seinen
Anmerkungen und den Erklärungen die wir
bekommen über die verschiedenen
Fassungen wie ein Labor das ja mal sehen
können wie funktioniert denn Zensur was
musste raus die Beispiel sie gerade
genannt habe was hat der Erzähler was
hat der Autor Grossmann wieder reingetan
wenn er konnte um das Bild komplett zu
machen die die Wirklichkeit
wiederzugeben und neben dem was sie
gerade erwähnt habe ist insgesamt
erstaunlich wie wenig Ressentiment
gegenüber den deutschen Staat dem
Faschismus nnt natürlich Faschismus
machen sie alle vorschriftsmäßig in dem
Buch aber es ist tatsächlich wenig
Ressentiment gegenüber den Menschen den
Deutschen gibt ja auch Soldaten Figuren
die durch ausgebrochen und interessant
sind die selber ich will nicht dass die
die Grossmann als verführte gesehen hat
als Gläubiger einer Sache und die im
Grunde in eine Höhle gelockt werden ja
das ist finde ich eigentlich sehr
vielschichtig dafür dass Grossmann auf
sowjetischen Boden stand und man Gefahr
lief dass das Ganze sowjetische Reich
untergeht ich möchte kurz anzufügen
leider oder zum Glück ich denke er zum
Glück für lese eine Lese der oder die
einfach an das Buch lesen wird im Buch
selbst ist ja nicht markiert er was zu
der Druckversion gehörte und was was ist
Robert Schindler für die englische
Ausgabe Ebene wieder hinein genommen hat
man das war eine sinniger Kampf von den
Rossmann da mehrere Jahre geführt hat
ist damit das vor wie so ein wie so ein
Handeln ja gut wenn ihr wenn ihr darauf
besteht dass ich das rausnehmen dann
möchte ich aber das hier drinnen drin
behalten wir haben ja auch das Beispiel
des Briefes sogar an Stalin wo er halt
darum dass sein Werk respektiert werde
es gibt ja auch dann einige Beispiele im
Anhang die uns erzählen wie er mit der
Feder Sheeran Zensur stellen umgegangen
ist aber sie haben völlig Recht darauf
hinzuweisen der Text hier ist sauber ja
der ist durch geschrieben und ein dicker
Roman der einlädt im Grunde sich in ihm
zu verlieren ihn zu lesen wie im 19
Jahrhundert die großen Epen die großen
beruht ärgerlichen Romane die nicht vor
allem aber auch im Sinn hatten den die
dazu packen und mitzunehmen eine fremde
Welt und dass das geschieht hier in ganz
human Sachsen uns ganz schnell und das
ist mir auch ein großes Anliegen muss
ich sagen dass die das heißt wir haben
gerade dieses Buch gelesen wir haben
aber auch einen schönen sieht er nicht
hier mit meiner Begeisterung davon davon
renne wir haben aber auch eine
interessante Spannung zwischen zwischen
einem Auto der einerseits sich ein
bisschen in dem
ideologischen Rahmen bevegt.de möglich
war und der dann drüber hinausschießt
und haben diese Spannung ständig Burnett
Dissident ja und Sowjetbürger wir haben
beides da aber vereint in einem großen
Künstler er hat im Grunde die ganze Zeit
entlang geschrieben an der Grenze des
Möglichen ist immer wieder drüber raus
gekommen also die Grenze überschritten
und das hat die Zensur da nicht
zugelassen als ist ein so heikles so
besetztes Thema gewesen zu der Zeit als
er es eben eingereicht hat dann bei den
Verlagen oder bei den Zeitschrift
Redaktion wir sollten vielleicht ein
Motiv mal raus Greif die hatten vorhin
schon gesagt seine Familiengeschichte
das ist richtig es gibt diverse Familien
mit Verwandtschaftsbeziehungen und
vielen Einzelschicksalen geht aber auch
durch bestimmte Berufe und durch soziale
Schichten ja eher wenn dir mal kurz ein
Schicksal besonders heraus greifen das
über beide Romane nämlich Stalingrad und
leben und Schicksal fortgeführt wird in
der Meere Figuren die fortgeführt werden
wir beide Bücher wobei man beide
natürlich einzeln lesen kann ich meine
jetzt Viktor Strom den Kernphysiker der
Jude ist und der seine Mutter und das
entspricht tatsächlich das eine
autobiografisches Element in diesem
großen Roman Stalingrad muss man selber
hat es nicht geschafft seine Mutter
herauszuholen nach Moskau zu holen bevor
in der Ukraine die Juden ins Ghetto
deportiert werden und später umgebracht
werden und er kann erst nach der
Niederlage der deutschen in Russland
erst danach kann er die Ukraine besuchen
und kann Erfa dass seine Mutter in der
Tat getötet worden ist und er schreibt
es eigentlich in diese beiden Bücher
hinein in der Figur dieses Strom und der
Brief der Mutter wandert im Stalingrad
Romania von Hand zu Hand und ist wie ein
Objekt was was geschieht mit Ihnen wenn
Sie so einen literarischen Kunstgriff
sehen Sie übersetzen den für uns das ist
da ist dieser Brief der Brief der Mutter
der also weitergegeben wird und dessen
Inhalt wir erst in Leben und Schicksal
hören ein langer Brief über die
Schilderung wie es im Ghetto ist ja das
ist ja doch eins der stärksten Motive in
suche Viktor Strom und die Reue darüber
dass er seine Mutter nicht retten konnte
und ich weiß nicht was was ist für sie
die wichtigste Episode
scheiß gibt es dachte das ist das ist
wirklich völlig unmöglich ich könnte
etliche
asiaquick die wichtigste was wichtig
Episode zumindest in dieser schwierigen
dazu finde ich den Roman zu komplex es
ist jetzt und dann zu vielschichtig und
es gibt viel zu viele interessante und
es gibt etliche Lieblingsfolgen von mir
und aber was jetzt diesen Brief betrifft
der ist ja in staden gerade an
Lehrstelle man Arndt man weiß eigentlich
was in dem Brief stehen muss aber da sie
jetzt schon auf den Brief gekommen sind
das ist eine meiner ja Lieblingsstellen
auch für mich als Übersetzerin gewesen
also es ist so wenn ich das kurz
erläutern darf und da sitzt Strom Dacia
vor Moskau er ist allein und es geht ein
Regen nieder ein Sommerregen und da wird
unglaublich schön beschrieben ich habe
mich sehr gefreut bei der Übersetzung
klanglich nämlich also was macht ihr um
euren Spaß wie die Tropfen fallen jeder
einzelnen Tropfen enthält einen an
Lichtfunken und es ist ein Moment
tiefsten Glücks und ich glaube die
formulieren lautet irgendwie das Glück
in dieser Welt zu leben
wenn's denn es ist Krieg und die
Situation ist ansonsten für ihn auch
überhaupt nicht einfach und dann
entsinnt er sich das irgendjemand immer
ein Päckchen gegeben hat und er kramt
danach und dann sich eben um diesen
dicken Brief er sieht das der von seiner
Mutter ist und beginnt ihn zu lesen und
dann wird sozusagen hat geschnitten und
es ist morgen in dem die Verdunklung ab
und schaut raus und alles ist voller Tau
und
dieser Traum wird wiedergegeben mit dem
Vergleich er sah aus wie spitzes
zerstoßenes Glas
und die die Bäume
explodierte vor Vogelgesang als Produkt
von dem Gesang der Vögel die ich zitiere
aus dem Kopf die mal einzeln mal
schlagartig gemeinsam oder auf einen
Schlag sangen mir ist wenn ich es jetzt
so berichte dann ist klar was er mit
seiner Tour Beschreibungen oft macht
Grundmann weil er verlegt seelisches bin
gerne in der Tour das tut er auf eine
wie ich finde wirklich zum Teil ganz
meisterhafte Weise und es ist viel
beiläufiger als durch meine Erzählung
gerade zum Ausdruck kam ich habe es beim
zweiten umsetzungs Durchgang diesen
zweiten Satz begriffen aber das da auch
aggressive Vokabeln sozusagen Begriffe
vorkommen explodieren laute explodieren
das war irgendwie vorbei mir so
untergegangen das da also im Grunde das
ganze Programm von von einer Pogromnacht
bis hin zum erschießen in diesen wenigen
Sätzen dass er das sieht er sieht es in
der Natur
[Musik]
ich habe meinen Phaeton Kollegen Andreas
Kilb mal gefragt ob er mir etwas zum
militärhistorischen Hintergrund aber
auch zur Psychologie des Drama von
Stalingrad sagen kann er ist sehr
interessiert an solchen Dingen hat
unendlich viel dazu gelesen oft darüber
geschrieben ich kann mich aus der
Kindheit an
so manche Erzählung erinnern Russland
erzählen Stalingrad weiß ich nicht aber
Russland auf jeden Fall es waren immer
Bruchstücke einer viel größeren
Geschichte die mir schien die aber nur
noch anekdotisch weitergetragen wurde
dennoch unendlich tiefe Spuren in der
Psyche viele Menschen hinterlassen haben
muss Menschen die vor mir da waren
Menschen die ich zum Teil nicht
kennenlernen konnte weil sie in Russland
gewesen war ja
das würde wahrscheinlich vor der
Wehrmachtsausstellung in den 90er Jahren
überhaupt nicht kollektiv aufgearbeitet
und es ist natürlich auch schwer und
welche Katastrophe ein solches blutiges
geschehen irgendwie Kollektiv auf zur
Arbeit es muss individuell bewältigt
werden die Ostfront Russland es war der
Inbegriff allen Schreckens weil dort
auch mehr als drei Viertel aller
deutschen Kriegsverluste eingetreten
sind und weil die Kampfar dort auch
Beweise brutal und entmenschlicht war
die bis dahin undenkbar gewesen die in
dem Sinne ist Stalingrad da nur eine
episode militärische noch
bedeutungsvoller war der Untergang der
Heeresgruppe Mitte 1944 aber Stalingrad
ist natürlich unendlich viel wichtiger
in der mentalitätsgeschichtliche weil es
auch Anfang vom Inneren Untergang des
Dritten Reiches war und darauf hat ja
Goebbels im Februar 43 mit einer
sportpalastrede vom totalen Krieg sofort
reagiert das Dritte Reich das Naziregime
musste die letzten Reserven mobilisieren
weil innerlich bei der Bevölkerung im
Grunde der Glaube an den Sieg bröckelte
und sich langsam auflöste wenn wir als
die Generation die wir sind mit unserer
Geschichte von Aufarbeitungen im Plural
etwa vor Holocaust Aufarbeitung über die
Jahrzehnte haben wir doch irgendwann
Erzählungen gefunden die gegenwärtige
Debatte um das Polen Denkmal in Berlin
zeigt dass es weitere Erzählungen gibt
oder geben könnte die mit Opfern im
Osten zu tun haben was also bloodlines
genannt wird von Timothy Snyder und
anderen wie kann denn überhaupt ein
heutiges Bewusstsein unser Bewusstsein
die Sowjet Herrschaft und dieser wir
Opfer und Stalingrad alte Dinge zusammen
denken wie ist das überhaupt möglich
ohne ungerecht zu sein ist nur möglich
indem man auf das individuelle Schicksal
und meinetwegen auch das Schicksal von
Gruppen aber nicht auf die Ideologie die
dahinter steht schaut es waren eben zwei
Diktaturen die dort aufeinander geprallt
sind 2 und Rechtsregime aber das macht
das Sterben der einzelnen in keiner
Weise weniger dramatisch und weniger
grausam und weniger ungerecht man so
will deswegen kann erinnerungen nur
ansetzen bei dem was wirklich geschehen
ist und bei dem Leiden was wirklich
erlitten wurde und in dem man sich von
den ideologischen Vorbedingungen dieses
Kriegs ein Stück weit löst und
tatsächlich auf die Individuen schaut
kann man die Erinnerung vielleicht
überführen in ein
kollektives Gedächtnis was dann zur
Befriedung Beiträge mal die die
Wehrmachtsausstellung auch jetzt
Jahrzehnte später noch mal anschauen ist
denn da so ein sickereffekt eingetreten
davon also eine gründliche
Demontage des Wehrmacht Mythos ganz
bestimmt aber ist auch einer dieser
Konsens entstanden zumindest ist die
Vorstellung dass bei dem Geschehen im
Osten irgendjemand der daran beteiligt
war sauber geblieben sei diese
Vorstellung ist endgültig passe ich
glaube die kann jetzt nur noch von der
rechten Kreisen wiederbelebt werden es
ist allen klar dass niemand der daran in
irgendeiner aktiven Weise teilgenommen
hat moralisch sauber war
der einzelne Mensch also
das bleibt übrig der Versuch den
einzelnen Menschen zu betrachten nämlich
unter seinen Bedingungen eben das was
alle große Literatur versucht was
manchen Filmen gelingt dass ich ihn
eingetragen werden in fremde Leben die
uns eigentlich wenig anzugehen scheinen
manchmal fast gegen unseren Willen zur
Teilnahme gebracht werden gibt es auch
bei Filmen so
Existenzen die wir eigentlich langweilig
finden müssen und vielleicht im
wirklichen Leben langweilig finden
würden und sie werden interessant
faszinierend sogar beide gut erzählt und
richtig dargestellt werden ich habe
Andreas Kilb dann noch gefragt was es
denn bedeutet mit der Hoffnung auf Sieg
zu kämpfen oder aber mit der nackten
Angst das alles zu Ende sein könnte
es gibt einen Aspekt an Stalingrad den
man als militärisch
mentalitätsgeschichtliche Wände
bezeichnen kann den ich sehr entscheiden
finde wenn Soldaten in ein Gefecht
ziehen indem sie wissen dass sie morgen
sterben werden sterben könnten dann ist
das Bewusstsein siegen zu können ganz
entscheidend was heißt das
Selbstvertrauen eine Armee eines Heeres
ist ganz entscheidend auch für die
Performance dieses Heeres und bis zum
Herbst nur seit 42 war eben die
Sowjetunion hauptsächlich auf dem
Rückzug unterbrochen von der
Winteroffensive ja aber sehr schnell
schon im Januar dass der 42 gestopft
worden war das hat sich eben mit Styling
gerade geändert von da an waren die
Rückschläge der sowjetischen Truppen die
Ausnahme und die sowjetischen Truppen
befand sich in der permanenten Offensive
und die Wehrmacht nur noch auf dem
Rückzug das heißt dabei einen Sieges
Bewusstsein auf einmal da auf der
sowjetischen Seite was ist vorher so
nicht gegeben hatte und innere Stärkung
hatte scheint dazu beigetragen dass der
Krieg sich gewendet hat nicht nur die
industrielle Produktion die
selbstverständlich vorher auch schon da
war diese Mentalität mäßige Stärkung hat
einfach ein großes Gewicht gehabt in
diesem Krieg weil kann sagen von Daten
wusste die Rote Armee dass sie siegen
würde und zwar nicht mehr aufgrund des
Mieters des russischen Winters der ein
Jahr zuvor noch eine Rolle gespielt hat
sondern wegen des neuen Mieters von
Stalingrad und hatte die Hitler Soldaten
aufgehört und man würde sie jetzt
zurückschlagen und dann würde sie
verfolgen bis nach Berlin es gibt
natürlich auch industrielle
Voraussetzung und noch mehr gibt es
militärische Voraussetzung die das
ermöglicht haben z.b. die
Zusammenfassung von Panzereinheiten
selbständig operieren und Verbänden ist
eine entscheidende Wende des Jahres und
der 42 dadurch wurde die russische
Taktik erheblich aggressiver offensiver
und es waren daneben Kesselschlachten
möglich bei den deutsche Verbände
eingeschlossen wurden nicht mehr
russische
[Musik]
ich sitze hier mit Christiane Körner
einer der drei Übersetzerinnen ich nenne
mal die anderen Namen noch einmal Maria
Raja
Andreas Weihe und Christiane Körner
diese drei haben über 1.200 Seiten
Stalingrad von Wassili Grossman
übersetzt ich habe das Vergnügen nicht
mit Christiane Körner zu unterhalten und
wir haben jetzt also hin und her
geblättert wo wollen wir denn mal
zitieren eigentlich wollen wir unendlich
viel zitieren aber eine Stelle befindet
sich am Ende des zweiten Teils als also
die Gefahr immer größer wird Stalingrad
ist eingekesselt die Gefahr wächst die
Bomben sind schon längst gefallen und da
gibt es eine Stelle auf dem Hof des
Bergwerks wo einer der Leute dort zu
Ende Aufbauen der Rede halten soll für
die Arbeiter schafft es ist dunkel die
Arbeit der drängenden bisschen näher
heran diese coole Kumpels und diesem
Mann Motor in dem Feld erst mal nicht so
richtig was ein Wasser sagen soll jetzt
erst sehr nervös und dann plötzlich
riecht es aus ihm heraus und ich möchte
diese zehn Zeilen mal kurz Vorlesen
ich erinnere mich als ich noch ein
kleiner Knirps war mein Vater wurde vom
Minenbesitzer gefeuert unsere Sachen
wurden aus der Wohnung geworfen auf die
Straße in dieser Wohnung waren meine
beiden Schwestern und ich geboren worden
und es war Herbst wie jetzt
Polizeiwachtmeister kamen Arbeiter
versammelten sich wir mussten weg aber
wohin denn das war unser zu Hause hier
hatten wir gearbeitet gelebt Großvater
und Großmutter begraben ich schaute
meinem Vater zu wir Abschied nahmen
hörte was er sagte und jetzt habe ich
graue Haare aber vergessen kann ich es
nicht ich kann einfach nicht wie denn
auch
Gestell ist so typisch für Grossmann auf
vielfältigste Weise weil er sieht die
Seele komplett der Mann will eigentlich
was anderes sagen aber er redet
persönlich plötzlich und das ist das was
er in dem Augenblick ist er ist ein Mann
der vor anderen steht und wie wenn er
nackt wäre und er taucht selber in seine
Seele ein in seine Erinnerung ein und es
gibt unendlich viele Stellen wo Cross
man sich als Psychologe zeigt unter
unter härtesten Bedingungen wäre der
Menschen ja im Krieg schildert alte
Junge
Kindersoldaten die tapferen die weniger
tapferen sie haben sicherlich auch
unendlich viele Lieblingsstellen wollen
Sie mal Frau Körner eine von uns raus
picken Sie haben gerade wieder die
Kinder genannt da gibt es so unglaublich
wunderschöne stellen weil es gibt auch
Stellen wo Grossmann ganz anders
plötzlich erzählt es gibt eine Stelle wo
über mehrere Seiten die ganze Erzählung
aus Repliken besteht also aus einem
Dialog auch ohne irgendwelche
kommentieren in werben noch zwischen
Frau und Mann die sich zufällig absolut
zufällig wir wiedergefunden haben er
Frontkämpfer und sie flüchtet das ist
unglaublich berührend auch mit was für
Strategien etwas für Verfahren
Betragsverfahren immer wieder arbeitet
bei dem ansonsten klassischen erzählen
die Stellen sind alle zu lang ich habe
eben von seinen Naturbeschreibung
gesprochen und wollte deshalb gerne noch
eine kurze Stelle ziemlich am Ende des
Buches wo es um die Kämpfe geht vorlesen
und dann erschien der Himmel wie von
Asche bedeckt er wurde ein klein wenig
heller während sich die Erde noch immer
mit Finsternis füllte die Linie die den
Himmel von der Erde trennte begangen zu
zerfallen ihre gradlinige Kontur zu
verlieren
Einkerbungen und Unebenheiten begannen
sich auf der Erdoberfläche abzuzeichnen
aber noch war das Licht nicht auf der
Erde angekommen der heller werdende
himmelhoch die Finsternis hervor und
bald darauf wurden die Wolken sichtbar
und eine von ihnen die am höchsten Stand
die allerkleinste schien gleichsam
Atemholen zu wollen und eine leichte
kaum sichtbare Röte legt sich wie
lebendige Wärme auf ihr blasses kaltes
Antlitz
ich finde daran so so so unglaublich
schön dass in diesem Erleben von nur von
Schrecken davon leiden von Schmerz von
Angst von Tod da muss irgendwie dann
doch ein menschliches Gefühl sein und
das ist jetzt hier diesen Zusammenhang
wo alles wirklich einfach nur noch so
heillos wirkt das ist es im Kollektiv
ist es jetzt einfach auf die Wolke auf
das seelenlosen zu überhaupt die Tippse
keine beseelte Natur
projiziert und gleichzeitig Denkmal
natürlich bei dem krassen kalten Antlitz
auch an den Tod wieder also ich finde
das meisterhaft es geht mir genauso es
sind ganz viele Stellen wo er plötzlich
wie wenn er raus trete aus der Handlung
die Landschaft den Himmel die Steppe
wird Beschreibung sind unglaublich und
es zeigt natürlich dass er alles sieht
das Grossmann tatsächlich sie haben es
ja vorhin auch sehr schön ausgedrückt
Rossmann sieht so viel zur selben Zeit
und er schafft es trotzdem nach einander
das zu erzählen dann muss es ja Orten es
ist ja eine gigantische Erzählung der
uns hier geliefert hat und es ist eine
große wärmt ja vorhin erwähnt eine große
textrekonstruktion die sich jetzt
endlich wie ein großes Buch ein
zusammenhängendes packendes und wirklich
meisterhaft geschriebenes Buch lesen ist
ich würde das ganze Übersetzung noch
etwas wissen wenn sich drei Leute
zusammentun dann nehme ich stark an es
ist Eile geboten ist das so das war so
ja sehr große Eile geboten Gott sei Dank
wurde dann als wir schon zum Teil fertig
oder fast fertig waren Entwarnung
gegeben und sie trug noch weiter
hinausgeschoben konnten ein bisschen
durchschnaufen und die Fluss Runden
waren dann nicht mehr so hektisch stell
mal bevor sie müssen einerseits
einteilen aufteilen sie haben den leicht
größten Teil von den dreien bekomme ich
habe mal genau nachgezählt aber alle
haben über 300 Seiten sie kommen fast
auf 500 andere kommen 350° 9 sich also
alle haben ein richtig kräftige Stück
und dann muss natürlich Lektor Lektorin
muss dann auch ein bisschen
synchronisieren und die Teile zusammen
sehen oder die treffen sich schon die
machen sie das das muss natürlich vorab
schon geschehen Ulrike Ostermeyer hat
das Lektorat gemacht ganz großartig aber
das muss man vorher schon justieren
sonst sonst kann das niemand
zusammenbringen und wenn drei ganz
unterschiedliche Übersetzerinnen da an
einem Text arbeiten es sind ja Figuren
kommen im ersten Teil vollkommen 3. Teil
vor weil Grossmann läuft und ob ich viel
Charakterisierung über die Dialoge und
das hat sie sprechen die Menschen und da
muss man natürlich sehr genau hinschauen
dass der Klang da ähnlich ist wie macht
man sowas jede Person die beteiligt ist
muss ich erstmal selbst im Klaren
darüber werden wie funktioniert der Text
was für ein Temperament was für eine
Haltung oder was für eine besagen
Unternehmen Temperatur hat so einen Text
wie sieht es aus mit mit der Lexik mit
der Syntax hat der Stilistik generell am
dann haben wir proben gemacht und uns zu
dritt überall schreibe Proben gebeugt
und haben dann angefangen aus zu
balancieren Moment jeder macht der Probe
ja sie vergleichen dann sie kritisieren
einander also kritisieren im neutralen
Sinne ja sie bewerten einander ein
bisschen was macht jeder von ihnen wir
versuchen dann zusammen zu kommen also
in dem er z.b. gesagt hat ein großes zu
große Frage bei so einem Romane des
Entstehungszeit ja immerhin schon viele
Jahrzehnte her ist ist dann natürlich
vorab Entscheidung auch wollen wir denen
in sprachlichen in die Jetztzeit heben
nein das wollten wir nicht dann hat man
das Problem es kann Anachronismen geben
wie empfinden alle drei beteiligten denn
die Lexik die Stilistik ist das jetzt
Google Patina ist es ein Anachronismus
rakter plötzlich was meinem Empfinden
nach Element in Mainz Kollegen nach
ragte etwas aus der heutigen Sprache
hinein als was was wir wie ein
Fremdkörper waren im also da hat mir
ziemlich viel zu diskutieren was einfach
sozusagen die dass man dass man sich
einpendelt Lexika alles und vor allen
Dingen auch was die mögliche Rede
betrifft das die Dialoge betrifft auf
einer stilistischen eben ja da sind wir
in der Zeit so irgendwie ungefähr wenn
sie auch sagen sie sie brauchen eine
Plattform oder ein Pool um
Rechercheergebnisse auszutauschen wir
haben von Terminologie Kriegs Dinge
Kriegsgerät Bomben Namen Fachausdrücke
muss also ist eine riesen Lexikon im
Grunde das war natürlich wir hatten
etliche Excel Tabellen mit mit der
fachtheologie und Fach die Melodie ist
nicht nur Gott sei erst geklagt das
militärische war damit habe ich mich am
wenigsten gern befassen aber es muss ja
nur sein das muss einheitlich ist muss
korrekt sein und es muss einheitlich
sein aber auch für Dinge wie Kleidung
oder wie Essen alltägliches
Gebrauchsgegenstände Autos Marken wie
auch immer wie wie geht man damit um wie
bezeichnet man was her und auch da immer
so ein austarieren wo sind wir sozusagen
Speedtest auf welcher Ebene und auch
chronologisch und dieses justiere
nachjustieren ist im Grunde die ganze
Zeit gelaufen und dann später noch
einmal ausgetauscht mit Texten das war
Nazi Mnich hitziger Arbeit denn es soll
Jan und wirklich ein Atem hinter im Text
sein ich hoffe es ist dann auch noch mit
der großen Leistung von Ulrike
Ostermeyer gelungen also der Eindruck
ist wirklich ein überwältigender es ist
eines der großen Buch knisse dieses
Herbstes dieses Buch und wir wünschen
ihm natürlich ein intensives und zu uns
und Reiches nach Leben wie das der
Vorgänger Leben und Schicksal der
chronologisch später kommt auch erfahren
hat dieses Werk Leben und Schicksal hat
Rossmann für uns erst Forum den 15 Jahre
ist jetzt schon her als Klassiker
etabliert wir kannten diesen Namen kaum
Wein DDR erschienen aber er war auch
meistens verstümmelt erschienen und
jetzt eben haben wir diese beiden großen
Bücher die eigentlich eines sind von
zusammen um die 2500 das also ist ein
ein Lektüre Hinweis dir nicht geben
möchte eine Empfehlung eine sehr warme
Empfehlung für Wassili Grossman Roman
Stalingrad ich danke Christiane Körner
sehr fürs Kommen es war eine riesige
Freude Sie da zu haben und ich
gratuliere Ihnen und Ihren Kollegen zur
dieser großen Fahrt vielen Dank Linde
[Musik]
Stalingrad von Wassili Grossman wurde
aus dem russischen übersetzt von
Christiane Körner dir soeben gehört
haben Maria reiche und Andreas Weise und
ist im Claassen Verlag erschienen der
Mann hat 1280 Seiten wiegt 1,5 kg ein
besonderer Service des frz Bücher
Podcast die Waage zu benutzen und er
kostet 35 € wenn sie uns schreiben
möchten unsere E-Mail lautet Bücher -
Podcast Apps faz.de Bücher mit OE
unser Literaturrätsel von tilman
Spreckelsen kommt nächste Woche
und am nächsten Sonntag gibt es hier in
Bücher Podcast eine Sonderfolge in 14
Tagen ist dann wieder der Kollege Kai
Spanke mit Sachbüchern dran und wir
hören uns wieder wenn Sie mögen am 2.
Januar wenn wir uns schon fast wieder
ins neue Jahr gewöhnt haben bis dahin
waren die es gut und auf bald
[Musik]
[Applaus]